- Oh my God, Chandler Bing, ah!
(upbeat music)
- Hey, I'm Laj Najiv from India.
- My name is Andero Arerro,
I'm from Mexico City, Mexico.
- I'm from Berlin, Germany.
- I'm from Scotland.
- I'm from New Zealand.
- And I'm from Israel.
- And I'm from London, England.
I'm from Saigon, Veitnam,
and this is my attempt
at the American accent.
Since my husband is from Michigan,
I decided I would do a midwestern accent.
Last time I went out with Brad
he spilled Faygo and Better Made chips
all over me at the Tiger's game.
My name is Tim.
You can call me Mit,
it's backwards for Tim.
In Minnesota, you know
all those people up there.
I love hockey man, and I was like,
"Oh, yeah, I love hockey too."
I love me some good Wisconsin cheese.
Hello there, I'm from America,
and I say words like aluminum
and spell color without the U.
I literally love bacon.
Bacon is love.
Bacon is everything.
Okay, so let's get back home to New York,
we like it over here.
Brooklyn's in the house.
So the last time I was in New York,
I was with a friend of mine called Joe.
You know, he looked at me and said,
"Did you (bleep) my wife?"
God that was very, very bad.
Hey, forget about it.
All right, already.
Get out of here.
Let's go to the store to get some coffee.
I would like a Dunkin' Donut.
How you doin'?
My name is Mike, I'm from Joysey.
You want to go over to Manhatten,
maybe get a slice, some coyffee?
I don't know, forget about it!
Eh, I'm walking here!
I think my favorite American accent to do
is the southern accent,
just cause I like the way that they talk,
and the way they pronounciate the words.
To me, the southern
accent sounds like this,
I'm going to chew tobacco all night long.
I was always saying to myself,
"Jump on the horse,
cowboy, and do your best."
Hey there, ma'am,
you all seem a little bit lost
and I thought I could come and help out.
Hey, ya'll, I'm from Alabama.
I live with my grandmom and my dog,
my, my dog, my (laughs)
I can't not do a New York accent.
So I'm going to do California.
And your eyebrows are like, um, sleek,
is that the word?
Like, oh my God,
it's like making fetch happen.
He's just really hot,
and like, I don't know, whatever,
like we just hooked up,
what's the big deal?
Josh is my (mumbling)
totally hot, six pack abs.
Josh, he's like so poor,
he doesn't have any money.
Like Josh, get your act together,
buy me some presents, yo.
It's the small things in our lives,
that keep us rolling and keep us going.
So we got to know how to
appreciate those things, right?
- Most of the comedy we
watch (mumbling) and sitcoms
are American.
This is just how we think you guys talk.
So no hard feelings, and peace out.
- [man] When I think of the midwest
I think of tornadoas in a big dust bowl,
and people doing
absolutely nothing at all.
Every single Indian who
goes down to America
and then comes back,
comes back talking like this.
So yeah, yeah, yeah.
Best of luck to you guys.